Accessibility of web content
requires semantic information about
user input widgets, structures, and
behavior, to allow specific technologies
to convey appropriate information
to people with disabilities.
So far we've looked at how to make a web
app accessible using a sensible DOM
order, which helps you create
a logical focus strategy,
which lays the groundwork for
a rich keyboard experience.
Both through the use of built-in
keyboard interactions and
sophisticated custom
keyboard event handling.
Using native elements for
optimal keyboard usability
also gives us the built-in
semantics used by assistive technology
to present a customized interface.
But we also need to think about
labeling controls and images and
being sure to add page structure using
headings and other semantic HTML
elements to provide landmark
information for assistive technology.
And finally the importance of links in
creating a rich interactive experience
in a complex site.
HTML comes with support for
all of those things built in.
And that gets us a really long way, but
sometimes it just doesn't
quite go far enough.
For example, so far there's no
standardized HTML element for
a drop down menu which is a pretty
commonly used UI metaphor.
And there are some more
subtle semantics like,
the user needs to know about
this as soon as possible.
So in this lesson, we're going to
learn how we can express semantics,
which HTML can't express on its own.